les champions et
m
championnat amateur
match d'harmonisation les connaissiez
explosion de joie pour nathan marie
cyrine nicolas arthur et la lie ce sont
ces collégiens de coignières qui ont été
désignés par le public de la merise pour
remporter le trophée de cette 19ème
édition du cycle mythe organisé par
déclic théâtre une année de travail
récompensé on n'arrive pas à y croire
première année on gagne la première fois
du coup bah c'est super et je sais pas
comment expliquer l enthousiasme
c'est génial gang des femmes à barbe ou
encore un avenir sans avenir
durant la soirée 4 collège de trappes et
long cours montigny le bretonneux et
coignières se sont affrontés sur ces
thèmes d'improvisation pour ces phases
finales quelques règles à respecter
comme la construction de l'histoire et
le respect de la langue française à la
fin de chaque passage le public donne
son verdict pour sa première
participation le collège la mare au sol
a remporté tous les suffrages
lydiane là avec juste la folie du jeu
est en fait du coup ils sont
complètement détachée de l'enjeu et
c'est ça qui a fait la différence
on a une grosse énergie véritablement
dans les collèges et ça c'est vraiment
très intéressant et au delà de cette
énergie de la créativité de l'imaginaire
cette année le championnat inter
collèges d'improvisation théâtrale a
réuni 15 établissements de saint quentin
en yvelines une participation record qui
pourrait bien augmenter pour la
prochaine édition
[Musique]